as the nation reels from a spate of
attempted mail bombings Democrats and
the media blamed President Trump
president Trump blames media and the
stock market tumble so it's good times
all around I'm Ben Shapiro this is the
Ben Shapiro show
a headline today that said that a man
burned down his house because they're a
bunch of spiders in his house and he was
trying to kill them with a blowtorch and
he proceeded to burn down his house and
I thought well that seems like a pretty
good metaphor for American politics
right we'll get to all of the latest in
just one second first let's talk about
how you can best invest I mean I know
that the stock market is really volatile
right now it feels like it's up and down
but the fact is that there's still a lot
of money to be made in investing in
smart fashion and this is where Robin
Hood comes in Robin Hood is an investing
app that lets you buy and sell stocks
ETFs options and Kryptos all
commission-free
they have a no Commission fee structure
other brokerages charge up to $10 for
every trade Robin Hood doesn't charge
commission fees you can trade stocks and
keep all the profits and they are really
beautifully designed one of the folks
who works here Caitlyn she uses Robin
Hood and she tells me that the user
interface is incredibly easy
she says that the portfolio value and
buying power tracking app is is really
really useful and she's new to
investment she says she has learned a
lot just using Robin Hood she basically
is learning to invest by using the app
and that's something that you can do too
right now Robin Hood is giving my
listeners a free stock like Apple Ford
or sprint to help build your portfolio
again they have all of these easy tools
things that make it easy for you to do
the research they have these stock
collections that are curated just for
you sign up at Shapiro dot Robin Hood
dot-com
that's cheap hero Robin Hood calm again
Shapiro dot Robin Hood calm and Robin
Hood is giving you a free stock like
Apple Ford or sprint to help build your
portfolio this app makes investing
really user-friendly and also really
teaches you how to invest you know we
have a lot of young listeners sort of
looking to get into the market this is a
great way of learning how to invest
Shapiro dot Robin Hood calm for that app
and the special deal okay so the latest
with regard to this spate of
quote-unquote attempted Mail bombings is
that it is possible that the bombs
themselves were not actually structured
to detonate so allah pundit over at hot
air rights judging by some social media
some of glanced at an AP story and
thought it was claimed that the
explosive powder inside the bomb was
harmless not so a package since CNN
contained a pipe bomb and an envelope
with a mystery powder inside it's a
mystery powder that's harmless the bombs
themselves are supposedly
workable and functional if crude
although there are other reports that
suggest that the bombs lacked a
detonator
so this was either a test run or a hoax
or something else like that we're still
waiting more information and that is the
key today awaiting more information it's
not the end of the world to say that we
need more information and this holds
true on every side yesterday I said
there are a bunch of folks who jumped to
the false flag explanation now I'm not
claiming that you are not allowed to
speculate inside your own head as to who
you think to this or that you're not
allowed to wonder whether there's enough
information to condemn one side or the
other what I am saying is if you are
100% sure this is a false flag if you
are 100% sure you went right there like
right away you just want to this is
probably the Democrats hosting
themselves that's not good okay you
shouldn't be using confirmation bias as
a substitute for evidence and this is
true in so many cases in our politics I
can't even tell you I've been saying
this for years I mean I remember when
with Michael Brown case Michael Brown
black guy shot by a cop and enormous
swaths of the left the entire left
basically said this is a case of police
racism and brutality in which a man was
shot in the back because he was black
and I said well let's wait for more
evidence and then the evidence came out
and it turns out that wasn't the story
at all well here if you're jumping to
either
this is Democrats hoaxing themselves or
this is Donald Trump planting bombs in
the mailbox is over at CNN let me
suggest to you that you're totally full
of crap hey you don't know you don't
know yet you know how I know you don't
know yet cuz no one knows yet I don't
know yet you don't know yet the press
don't know yet and anybody's suggesting
they know who did this or why it was
done or what the connection is to any
particular political party is lying to
you they don't have the information yet
now there's some indicators that
something weird is going on I mean what
did this this person who should be put
in jail forever the person who is doing
this has now sent one of these packages
to Robert DeNiro I guess and sent one to
Maxine Waters
and a picture of the of one of the bombs
at the CNN Bureau appears to have a
parody of an Isis flag taken from a meme
that was circulating on right-wing
corners of the internet since 2014
according to NBC News the printout
appears to show a parody flag that
replaces Arabic characters with a
silhouette of three women in high heels
and a middle inscription reading get er
done which is the catchphrase of Larry
the Cable Guy Daily Beast Lockland
marquee first noted that an image that
appeared inside the explosive package
sent to CNN's Time Warner building an
address to Brennan for a striking
similarity
black-and-white flag of the terror group
and then they confirmed this was in fact
an Isis flag parody so this is leading
people on the left to suggest that
really what this is is a right-wing hoax
and people on the right to suggest this
is a left-wing hoax and again again you
don't know I don't know nobody knows but
here's what I do know I don't really
believe that this is a person who sits
up nights thinking president Trump is
telling me to go bomb people and I don't
believe this is a person who's sitting
up nights going people on the left are
telling me to bomb people I think this
person is a crazy person I think this
person is a loon bag who wants to pursue
violence how do I know that because
they're sending bombs to Robert DeNiro
Robert DeNiro they said this is not
somebody who smacks of I'm a I'm a
sophisticated domestic terrorist with a
serious political agenda deeply
intertwined with the workings of modern
politics and here's where it gets
dangerous I said this yesterday people
who are immediately jumping to Trump's
rhetoric cause this or the media's
rhetoric cause this those people are
undermining the First Amendment because
the First Amendment basic guarantee is
that if I am not inciting you to
violence in my incitement to violence I
mean saying go bomb someone then I am
NOT responsible for your violent actions
you know who's responsible for the
violent actions here
the guy who put together bombs and
mailed them to people that's the guy
responsible not President Trump not CNN
not any of these folks just as Bernie
Sanders was not responsible for a Bernie
Sanders supporter going and attempting
to shoot up a congressional baseball
game and just as Barack Obama was not
responsible for a apparent fan of Barack
Obama trying to shoot up police officers
in Dallas President Trump is not
responsible for this the media are not
responsible for this and I don't have to
wait for the outcome to know that you
know why because the sort of rhetoric
that president Trump's use has used as
much as I dislike it as much as I have
ripped it on this program for years he
has never once said go mail bombs to my
political opponents and shouting lock
her up is not the same thing as saying
mail her a bomb they may raise the
temperature it may be bad for our
politics it may in fact lead people to
condemn each other at higher rates we
talked about that yesterday but it is
not in fact incitement to violence the
standard for incitement to violence is
extraordinarily high under American law
as well it should be well President
Trump reacted to all of this yesterday
and his first statement was we all have
to unify you know these are trying times
but we all have to understand that
violence is not appropriate
and I just want to tell you that in
these times we have to unify we have to
come together and send one very clear
strong unmistakable message that acts or
threats of political violence of any
kind have no place in the United States
of America okay well that seems about
the right answer
doesn't it that's the right answer and
what he really should add at the end of
that is listen I use charge Frederic my
opponents use charge Frederic maybe we
all should take a step back and tone
that down but the reality is that nobody
not me not my political opponents nobody
has actually incentivized this kind of
violence in the United States nobody in
the United States is inciting this kind
of violence in mainstream political
rhetoric which is true okay if you
actually want to see mainstream violence
being pushed by political agitators all
you have to do is look at actual
governments in Iran where they literally
chant death to America and call for
violence against Jews all you have to do
is look at the government of the
Palestinian Authority or Hamas actual
terrorist groups all you have to do is
look at governments around the world
repressive governments around the world
that make clear they want violence done
to their political opponents even
president Trump's worst statements where
he's making jokes about Greg Ginn for it
which you talked about last week body
slamming reporter there is an actual
difference it turns out between body
slamming a reporter and bombing someone
now if somebody went out and punched a
reporter and said I did it because
President Trump was making this sort of
remark about Reggie and forte and making
the light of that I would say okay
there's at least some connection there
but I'm not gonna say that there's a
connection between people sending mail
bombs to Maxine Waters and the President
of the United States saying that Maxine
Waters is a very low IQ individual we
say that kind of stuff about each other
all the time in a free country
maybe it's not the best thing to say but
that doesn't mean it's an incitement to
violence this kind of stuff has to stop
it really does but the media are not
stopping it and president Trump fires
back in just a second the media
obviously are not lowering the
temperature it's amazing to watch
members of the media claim that violent
rhetoric began with President Trump or
overheated rhetoric not violent rhetoric
overheated rhetoric began with President
Trump if it weren't for Trump we
wouldn't have anything like this really
risin risin was sent to senator Susan
Collins two weeks ago a year and a half
ago a Bernie Sanders supporter shot or
attempted to shoot
six congresspeople and nearly killed the
House Majority Whip Donald Trump juniors
wife was sent in actual toxic substance
she had to go to the hospital for it
there's like two and a half months ago
no this is not all Trump no it didn't
start with Trump this has been true in
the United States for a very long time
people use charged political rhetoric
that does not mean violence is okay but
violence has been commonplace in
political circles for literally decades
in the 1960s and 1970s bombings were
actually quite routine in the United
States well they're not routine thank
God now and we have an eye out for them
as well we should but to pretend that
Everett the world began spinning with
President Trump is just absurd
especially considering some of the
rhetoric that is used on a fairly
frequent basis by folks on the left
about President Trump himself so for
example today in The New York Times or
yesterday in The New York Times there's
an actual piece in The New York Times
it's a it's a fiction piece says five
novelists imagined Trump's next chapter
yeah this is in the New York Times it's
in their book review section and here's
what they say they say our focus here at
the book review is on books and stories
but also on how the books being written
and read reflect the world outside of
books and one of the biggest stories out
there of course is the Muller
investigation and the relationship
between Trump and Putin it's hard not to
speculate about what might happen next
to that and we thought who better than
some of today's most talented spy and
crime novelists one of these novelists a
person named Zoe sharp here's what Zoe
sharp rode is in the pages of the New
York Times Book Review
okay quote the Russian landed at Dulles
after 48 hours of traveling of necessity
he came from Moscow by a secure this
route a long way with a very specific
task there would be no return flight in
the airport bars the TVs were tuned to
different news channels but the story
was the same first the president's
campaign manager then his lawyer
Republican congressman former aides
family members those who weren't
indicted were subpoenas house arrests
had become fashionable and then it goes
on and on about how this guy was
basically shadowing the President of the
United States and here's where we're as
OE sharp gets to the key when it was
time he went downstairs took his place
in the lobby before the entourage
appeared the hotel staff had been lined
up to see their boss the president go by
a few of them applauded most did not the
president didn't seem to notice he waved
in his de sultry fashion the Secret
Service agents clustered around him
assured him toward the armored limo
idling outside at the curb the Russian
waited until they were a few steps past
before he drew the gun
he cited on the center of the
president's back and squeezed the
trigger the Makarov misfired the Secret
Service agents at the president's
shoulder heard the clicks spun into a
crouch he registered the scene instantly
drawing his own weapon with razor edge
reflexes the Russian tasted failure he
closed his eyes and waited to pay the
cost it did not come he opened his eyes
the Secret Service agents stood before
him presenting his Glock but first here
the agent said politely used mine and
this was printed in the New York Times
the same day that the media decided that
President Trump was the one who was
pursuing violent rhetoric and was the
only one pursuing violent rhetoric hey
let's all take a step back here everyone
is overheated it needs to stop a few
things can be true at once one wait for
all the evidence - don't blame
nonviolent but overheated rhetoric for
violence and three if you want to take
the temperature down you have to obey
one and two if you want to take the
temperature down wait for evidence and
don't blame people for violent acts by
third parties unless they are actively
telling the third parties to commit the
violent acts you want about our country
that's what we're all gonna need to do
and that means don't jump to
confirmation by us as soon as humanly
possible ok I'm gonna get to the media's
response to all of this which is just
egregious and then president Trump's
response to the media basically everyone
is acting badly here everyone is acting
as badly as can be which has become the
usual state of affairs in American
politics it's really quite awful but
we'll get to that in just a second first
let's talk about how you brush your
teeth so one of most important things
you do for your health every day is to
brush your teeth in fact studies show
that if you don't brush your teeth
properly can actually put in your
general health at risk well this is why
you need to quit quit was designed to
make brushing your teeth more simple
affordable and even enjoyable I have the
clip electric toothbrush it is fantastic
it travels really easily it is small it
is lightweight it doesn't require me to
take a giant charging station it has
sensitive sonic vibrations it is gentle
on your sensitive gums it has a built-in
two-minute timer that pulses every 30
seconds to remind you when to switch
sides because most of us don't actually
brush our teeth for long enough they
have a multi-use cover that mounts to
your mirror in tea clutters your sink or
cabinet makes traveling much much easier
and brush heads are automatically
delivered on a dentist recommended
schedule every three months for just
five bucks quip is one of the first
electric toothbrushes accepted by the
American Dental Association it has
thousands of verified five-star reviews
I love my clip electric toothbrush I
bring it with me everywhere again go
check it out quip it starts at just 25
bucks and if you go to get quick calm
Shapiro's right now you get your first
refill pack for free with equip electric
toothbrush that's your first refill pack
free and get quick comm slash up here oh
that's GE t qu IP comm Shapiro hey so
the media have decided that President
Trump is to blame which was predictable
now again I'm old enough to remember
when I said and many like me on the
right said Bernie Sanders is not to
blame for the Congressional baseball
shooting the left has no such qualms the
mainstream left has no such qualms so
Paul Waldman in the Washington Post
actually just blames the President of
the United States straight out
he just blames him straight out he says
allow me to suggest that blame is too
narrow a way to make sense of a series
of attempted bombings aimed at precisely
the people Trump and other Republicans
spend a huge amount of time vilifying we
don't have to look for clues about
whether the person responsible has a
magda hat or what their party
registration is we don't have to assign
direct blame beyond a reasonable doubt
what we can say is this given what Trump
has Trump has done and said this was
absolutely predictable
in fact it's wonder it took this long so
in other words we don't need to wait for
evidence right this is a guy who's it
overtly making the case in one of the
nation's premier newspapers you don't
need to wait for evidence and if you
wait for evidence then you are doing
something wrong instead I'm gonna jump
to the conclusion I want to jump to
which is that President Trump is
responsible for all of this here's what
Waldman says it's not just that Trump
advocates violence against his political
opponents though he does it's that
everything about his rhetoric pushes his
supporters in that direction even if the
overwhelming majority will never quite
get to the point where they'll actually
commit this kind of act of terrorism
okay well there are those of us on the
right who felt that President Obama
verged pretty easily on promoting
violence sometimes when he talked about
what the police were wouldn't talked
about how the police were overtly and
and systemically racist when he said
that sort of stuff we felt like okay
well you know is that an indication that
maybe violence is okay
there are folks in New York who felt
that way people on the NYPD who felt
that way that so much so that when bill
de blasio after ripping the police for
months actually went to a policeman's
funeral who was shot to death members of
the NYPD turned their back on him was
Bill de Blasio responsible for the
violence no he wasn't was Barack Obama
responsible for the violence no he
wasn't and you know what yeah
have to wait for evidence if you're
gonna even make that case because that
case is extraordinarily and the the bar
for evidence is extraordinary hi here if
you want to blame somebody for violence
and citement you actually have to have
evidence but the left doesn't care about
evidence they're not interested in
evidence and this prompted jeff zucker
to sound off so jeff zucker is the head
of CNN let's all remember cNN has not
been particularly measured in its
rhetoric with regards to the presidents
of the United States or with regard to
the right every conspiracy theory that
has been promoted against President
Trump has been actively pushed by the
folks at CNN everything and they've
spent two years fulminating over
supposed Russian collusion every day on
the air non-stop hey folks on the left
they love CNN specifically because CNN
has basically become a propaganda outlet
in many ways for the anti-trump agenda
but Jeff Zucker says that when a bomb
was sent to CNN headquarters then that's
because of President Trump so here is
what Jeff Zucker said he put out a
statement he said there is a total and
complete lack of understanding at the
White House about the seriousness of
their continued attacks on the media the
president and especially the White House
press secretary should understand their
words matter thus far they've shown no
comprehension of that again I do not
understand why Jeff Zucker thinks that
the President of the United States is
responsible for a bomb being sent to CNN
headquarters just because the president
says that he doesn't like the press or
the press or the enemy of the people I
don't like that language either I think
that language is bad but that is not
language saying go send a bomb to the
people at CNN that's not a thing the
president of the United States in
response to the media basically ginning
up outrage at him and at the right is I
think not entirely inappropriate so
first of all I will say this president
Trump has used rhetoric I don't like at
all he's used rhetoric that I think is
immoral with regards to the press I
think he has used rhetoric with regard
to his political opposition that is
immoral does that mean again he is
inciting violence no and the press have
used very similar rhetoric about
President Trump does that mean they are
inciting violence no it doesn't heated
rhetoric and violent rhetoric are not
the same thing and to link the two means
that eventually somebody's just going to
say well a censor all the rhetoric
otherwise it's gonna lead to violence
here is President Trump going after the
media basically the media and President
Trump can't stop clobbering each other
and I think there's some truth on both
sides and there's a lot of false in on
both sides here's the president saying
stop with the media scares the media
also has a responsibility to set a civil
tone and to stop the endless hostility
and constant negative and oftentimes
false attacks and stories have to do it
okay now I agree with the president that
the media to a horrible job of covering
the news and in response to President
Trump they promote even more falsehood
and more fakery and more divisive
politics this is what they do but is
there any question that President Trump
is trolling them of course not because
President Trump has used similar
rhetoric about the media basically this
is two folks slapping each other and
Napoleon Dynamite style in the face and
then blaming each other when a guy down
the street decides he's gonna go bomb
the local school not the same thing she
tweeted out President Trump asked
Americans to come together and send one
very clear strong unmistakable message
that acts or threats of political
violence of any kind have no place in
the USA you chose to divide an attack
America should unite against all
political violence okay that is correct
that is correct and I don't understand
why President Trump is getting bashed
for saying the right thing at that at
that rally oh oh or at the White House
and then he is getting bashed on the
other side when he when he goes after
the media anyway yeah in any case CNN
demonstrating full scale that they are
going to go with this narrative right
they never went with this narrative with
regard to Bernie Sanders they never went
with this narrative with regard to the
the attempted attacks on Susan Collins
but they are gonna go full-scale with
these attacks on President Trump so
here's CNN's Gloria Borger saying you
know Trump's targets is is it a
coincidence president Trump attacks a
bunch of people and then those people
get mail bombs you know what we do in
politics we attack people on the other
side and their and their ideas I attack
people on the other side all the time
does that mean I'm calling for a bombing
of their house of course not and people
who attack me online are not calling for
a bombing of my house that's not a thing
but here's Gloria Borger blaming Trump
you know these are names as you point
out that come up all the time in his
rallies I mean he's not particularly
kind to Barack Obama either so
I think it would have behaved him to be
a little bit more complete so now we are
going to conflate we're going to
conflate President Trump
ripping Barack Obama with President
Trump calling for violence against
Barack Obama if that's the case than CNN
calls for violence against Donald Trump
every single day because CNN spends its
days ripping on President Trump and now
we are conflating criticism of political
figures with a call for violence against
those political figures it's just this
is bad stuff you can you can condemn
rhetoric you don't like without blaming
it for violence in yet as we'll see
folks in the media and folks on the
Democratic side of the aisle are more
than happy to you know they like to use
the word weaponized to weaponize
politics in particular in this fashion
in order to try and push for a ban
basically on their opposition we'll talk
about all of that in just one second but
first let's talk about emergencies so
emergencies are usually called
emergencies because they strike without
warning because you don't know anything
about them in advance and that's why you
should prep now in case there is some
sort of emergency you know the
government says that you really ought to
have a supply of food and water in your
home and there's no question you should
hurricane Michael hit with very low
warning with earthquakes there is no
warning I live in California where this
sort of thing happens relatively
frequently when it's breaking news it's
too late to prepare because now you have
to scramble the best thing to do is
prepare for emergency situations while
things are calm ask yourself if you
actually have the supplies you need for
your family if god forbid you have to be
without for a couple of weeks if not
right now go to my Patriot supply and
get a two week food kit to get you
started this week it's on special for
just 75 bucks when you go to my special
website prepare with Ben's calm or call
eight eight eight eight oh three
fourteen thirteen that's eight eight
eight eight oh three fourteen thirteen
the food kits include meals that last up
to 25 years in storage order now prepare
yourself so there no surprises eight
eight eight eight oh three fourteen
thirteen go to prepare with Ben calm
that's prepared with Ben calm again
eight eight eight eight oh three
fourteen thirteen or two go check them
out and prepare with then.com I have to
say that I think that the reaction of
the left on this has been absolutely
abysmal immoral just bad when when they
suggest that President Trump not liking
his political opposition is to blame for
somebody sending bombs to members of his
political opposition all I have to say
is you are trying to outlaw politics in
the end what you're trying to do is the
outlaw your political opposition when I
spoke at Berkeley
there are people outside chanting
speeches violence that's basically the
chant that's happening in CNN
headquarters here but it's completely
hypocritical by the way also because
what the left and what the folks at CNN
really mean is that speech is only
violent if it is coming from the right
here's an example so Don Lemon rips into
Trump he says now President Trump is
blaming members of the media and he's
being mean and he's being cruel it's not
nice he's blaming members of the media
who are really the victims in all of
this well let's be real they're the
victims of the bomber but they're not
necessarily the victims of President
Trump the media can stand on their own
two feet and they are fully capable of
fighting back against the President as
they have been for the last three years
here is Don Lemon saying President Trump
blamed the victim blame the victim
tonight he for him to sit there and
blame us we're the victims here and only
us it's disgusting
he says you know what were the victims
here we're the victims here again CNN
were the victims but not of President
Trump not when it comes to this okay
President Trump was saying that the
overheated rhetoric on the part of the
media are contributing to a bad
environment in the United States and the
response of the folks in the media is
let's overheat the rhetoric even more
and I'm sorry but this is this is
overdone okay the you know Chris Cuomo
and Tom lemon on CNN hugging each other
outside of CNN you know in the middle of
a segment here here's them doing this do
better and take the grace and take the
opportunity to be better I love you
brother thank you thank you very much be
careful you know all these folks who are
who are acting as though there's some
sort of existential threat to the media
in the United States I'm sorry no I'm
sorry no there isn't okay this is a bad
incident there's no question it's a bad
incident the reason I have a little bit
of lack of sympathy for this we almost
died here routine is because this thing
was stopped in the mail room with no
detonator on it apparently my Jewish
high school used to be evacuated three
times a year for bomb threats minimum
three times a year and you know what it
wasn't people hugging and kissing
outside because there are crazy people
out there there are crazy people out
there but the way that CNN is treating
this is that it's not crazy people it's
perfectly sane people who are being
directed by the President of the United
States to attack them they're an
institution under assault by the
president
who is calling for violence on behalf of
his of his political friends no no and
you don't get to do this I'm sorry Don
Lemon does not get to do this routine or
the media are the victims at the same
time that he is out there claiming that
an tyfa is wonderful this is just a
couple of months ago there's just a
couple of months ago Don Lemon claiming
that an Tifa an actual violent terror
group in the United States is totally
fine no one condones of violence but
there were different reasons for antifa
and for these neo-nazis to be there one
racist fascists the other group fighting
racist fashions they're not that bad I
mean they're just fighting racist
fascist antiva it's it's just again
everyone is garbage okay
moral of today's show everyone is
garbage including Chris map your ever
they say oh yeah I'm near the evidence
gap in the morning come every show run
in here getting this really gyro RAL
crazy like and then just talk about
whatever pops in my brain say Kathleen
get me coffee just get your own coffee
Chris and I say okay fine then I come in
without any convicts and too lazy go god
machine go chris matthews go they say
there is no connection between what
Trump has said about Hillary Clinton
Barack Obama Eric Holder John Brennan
and CNN and the thinking of the person
who sent those pipe bombs is foolhardy
how do you know that you don't know that
he doesn't know that because he doesn't
know things and yet everybody assumes
the worst on behalf of everybody else
and instead of us saying there's a
difference between he had political
rhetoric and violent political rhetoric
we just jump in with both feet
the Democrats are even worse than the
media on this because the Democrats are
absolutely hypocritical and absurd so
Nancy Pelosi and Chuck Schumer put out a
statement on this on these attempted
bombings and here is what they said is
Emily Zanotti reporting over at Daily
wire she says Senate Minority Leader
Senator Chuck Schumer and House Minority
Leader Nancy Pelosi lashed out at
President Donald Trump in a statement
released Wednesday afternoon the pair
jointly condemned a statement from the
President issued earlier in the day
expressing his concerns over a series of
suspected explosive devices sent to
prominent Democrats they say we listened
with great interest to the president's
remarks this afternoon we all take an
oath to support and defend the
Constitution and protect the American
people and that is our first
responsibility however President Trump's
words ring hollow
until he reverses his statements that
Cantone acts of violence time and again
the president has condoned physical
violence and divided Americans with his
words and actions expressing support for
the congressman who body-slammed a
reporter
vo neo-nazis who killed a young woman in
Charlottesville his supporters at
rallies who got violent with protesters
dictators around the world who murdered
their own citizens and referring to the
Free Press as the enemy of the people
now I think President Trump says a lot
of bad stuff have I been unclear about
this but you're actually gonna blame him
for this bombing spate this is this is
what you're gonna do now I seem to
remember somebody named Nancy Pelosi
just about a year and a half ago who has
asked about Steve Scalise nearly being
shot to death he almost died okay he was
in critical condition he almost died
it's a miracle that he lived here is
Nancy Pelosi saying how dare you blame
us or Bernie Sanders for heated rhetoric
that could have been connected with the
guy going on to a baseball field and
shouting as he guns down members of
Congress about health care that's really
what he's doing he was standing there
screaming about health care well he
tried to murder members of Congress here
was a Nancy Pelosi's response at the
time she was right then she's not right
now what's the difference now she gets
to target right-wingers how dare they
say such a thing
how dare they so this sick individual
does something Despicable and it was
horrible what he did hateful but for
them to all of a sudden be sanctimonious
as if they don't never seen such a thing
before it's just it's it's just amazing
so she's reversed I mean I wonder what
changed oh what changed is who's gonna
get blamed that's what changed so there
is no such thing as a sword that cuts
both ways all we have in the United
States at this point are a bunch of
hatchets right blunt on one end directed
toward you and sharp on the other end
directed toward your opponent we don't
recognize that what we're actually
holding is a sword and if you use it on
your opponent it can easily be turned
back on you every sword has two edges
but according to the left it's just a
hatchet and you can bury it between the
shoulder blades of your political
opponents Hillary Clinton does the same
thing so we former first lady senator
presidential candidate she says listen
as an American I'm worried about the
level of our rhetoric well as a person
I'm great as an American I'm worried I
worry about the direction of our country
I worry about what kind of world will be
waiting for them when they're teenagers
and young adults and beyond okay and it
wasn't just teller a Clinton saying this
her top aide Philippe Raines who is
really one of the most vicious people in
American politics he was on MSNBC and he
explicitly just blamed President Trump's
rhetoric for all of this this is someone
who has weaponized Trump's Twitter feed
and made it into a hit list he is
addicted to their response and they are
response they are addicted to his
vitriol okay so next time somebody who's
a big Hillary Clinton fan decides to go
and shoot up an office or invade a Fox
News studio then I guess we can blame
Hillary Clinton because after all I
recall when a minute ago one minute ago
Hillary Clinton was saying you cannot be
civil with the other side okay this is
legitimately what's the day today today
is the 25th ok so legitimately 24 14
days ago 15 days ago Hillary Clinton
said this you cannot be civil with a
political party that wants to destroy
what you stand for what you care about
that's why I believe if we are fortunate
enough to win back the house and/or the
Senate
that's when civility can start again but
until then the only thing that the
Republicans seem to recognize and
respect is strength
ok everybody is completely full of crap
everyone is completely full of crap well
get to the fullness of the crap in just
one second but first let's talk about
your ancestry so you may have noticed
that Elizabeth Warren released a genetic
report recently it found that she is
whiter than any human being ever found
on planet Earth
that she's as white as the as the moon
at full waning I had full waxing and
that that's how white Elizabeth Warren
is we wouldn't have known that
except for genetic testing would you
like to find out whether you're more
Native American than Elizabeth Warren
well then you should go check out
23andme it's a DNA testing service that
can offer insights into your ancestry
health wellness and traits it's actually
a lot of fun and it's really easy to do
you simply spit into a tube provided in
your 23andme kit and then you mail your
gunk back to the lab to be analyzed the
bitter taste report and sweet vs. salt
reports can tell you how your DNA plays
a role in determining food preferences
and help you change what kind of flu
you eat sleep reports telling you if
you're much more likely to be an
especially deep sleeper you can have the
saturated fat and weight reports which
tells you how your weight might be
affected by saturated fats in your diet
so you can actually change your diet and
lactose intolerance report that Shutts
insights into how your genetics could
affect your ability to digest dairy
products it's a lot of fun and you're
finding out know where you come from
which is cool
order your 23andme health an ancestry
service kit at 23andme dot-com / appear
oh that's the number 23 2 3 and me.com
slash Shapiro go check them out right
now and brag to your friends about
whether you are in fact more Native
American than a senator from
Massachusetts who says that she's Native
American go check it out right now
23andme comm slash Shapiro go check it
out okay so again hey everyone is full
of crap including Andrew Cuomo and Bill
DeBlasio
both of them came out they said listen
we have to turn down the temperature in
this country and it has to start at the
top weird
I remember when Bill DeBlasio was saying
the police officers were just shooting
black people for no reason and I
remember when Andrew Cuomo or the
governor of New York said that everyone
who disagrees with him on politics
should get out of the state that is not
an exaggeration he said that there is no
place in the state of New York for you
if you don't believe in same-sex
marriage and his views on social issues
but don't worry it's just it's the
rhetoric on the other side that's a
problem let me explain if you are
sitting around today and are going it's
always the rhetoric on the other side
that's a problem by a freaking mirror by
a freaking mirror okay everybody has a
role in tamping down some of the
rhetoric here everybody does and that
also means that blaming the other side
and suggesting that the other side is
responsible for violence is leading to a
worse country it's so funny everybody
thinks they're fighting violence when
they suggest the other side is
responsible for violence when they just
use mainstream political rhetoric you're
actually increasing the chances of
violence when you do that because you
are heating everything up you're
suggesting the other side is so evil
that the very uh pterence of their ideas
is likely to lead to death chaos and
destruction that isn't that that's an
unamerican perspective it's unamerican
Bernie Sanders can say whatever the hell
he wants no matter how wrong he is and
unless he's actively saying go shoot
people on a congressional baseball field
that is not his fault and Donald Trump
can say whatever he wants and you don't
have to like it but whatever Donald
Trump says he has the right to say that
so long as he is not saying go beat up
somebody right now go bomb in some place
right now okay we'll get to more of this
in just one second plus a couple of
other crazy stories that are worth
noting but you're gonna have to
subscribe $9.99 a month gets you the
rest of this show live that gets you the
rest of the Andrew Clavin show live the
rest of the Michael Noel's show live it
gets you access to our Sunday specials
this week we have on Scott Adams which
is fun also next week we have a big-name
guests and that one's especially fun so
you're gonna want to check that out as
well and when you spend $99 a year you
get all of those wondrous things Plus
this the leftist here's hot or cold
tumblr also you get access to our
mailbag so if you actually want to ask a
question and have your question answered
and your life improved immeasurably all
you have to do is spend some cash and it
will make it happen for you go over to
daily wear comm and become a subscriber
it helps also support the program
obviously helps us keep our otherwise
unemployable staff employed go check it
out right now we are the largest
fastest-growing conservative podcast in
the nation
[Music]
if I sound weary of all of this it's
because I am weary of all of this really
I mean if we're gonna have any sort of
level-headed conversation we're gonna
have to stop blaming each other for
every crazy person who does a crazy
thing
this guy's a crazy person okay this
isn't somebody in the White House this
isn't somebody at the DNC headquarters
this is a crazy person by the way
there's a lot more connection
politically between a guy who was in
actual democratic staff or daxing
Republican members of Congress like two
weeks ago then there is relation between
this person and Donald Trump or this
person in CNN enough is enough folks
really really let's stop making the
country a worse place I don't feel like
this is preachy because I think this is
just common sense and I think most of
the people listening understand that
them gross okay
in other news NBC News is actively
hyping this megyn kelly blackface thing
and it's really stupid
it's really stupid so speaking of
stupidity in politics so megyn kelly we
talked about this at length yesterday
megyn kelly said on a show that she
doesn't really understand why this woman
who was in the real housewives of
whatever why this woman was in trouble
for dressing up as Diana Ross at a party
because when she was a kid people used
to darken their skin for Halloween
costumes and it wasn't a big deal and a
bunch of folks said well blackface has a
long an inglorious history in the United
States that's insensitive she said you
know what I learned something today
that's insensitive I was wrong that
seems like that should be an end of the
story does anyone really believe megyn
kelly is a brutal vicious racist does
anyone actually believe that of course
nobody believes that nobody actually
believes that megyn kelly thinks black
people are inferior genetically and if
black people are worse
black people are morally culpable at a
higher level than white people or any of
that no one actually believes that at
NBC and this just shows you that
capitalism when used by bad people you
know is not great okay
NBC wants to get rid of megyn kelly they
want to get rid of megyn kelly because
they tried to push megyn kelly into a
box that is not properly fitted for
megyn kelly megyn kelly is an excellent
interviewer she's an excellent question
er she's a former lawyer and prosecutor
that is where her role is best they
tried to fit her into the Katie Couric
fluff-fluff Morning News routine and
that didn't work for them and so the
ratings were not good and so they had
signed her to an inordinate amount of
money and now they're trying to push her
out the door how are they doing that by
acted by actively stoking racial
resentment in the United States I mean
ugly stuff NBC News is now saying
they're going to air take two episodes
of Megan's show this week and they're
going to seek to terminate her contract
based on her saying that she didn't
understand what the big deal was about
somebody darkening their face for a
Halloween costume now does anyone really
believe that the NBC brass is really
upset about that or that a boycott is on
its way or that this was actually
vicious brutal KKK style racism anyone
actually think that no of course not
this is just the NBC News trying to
stoke racial resentment for purposes of
being able to fire somebody the head of
NBC News Andy lack he openly lit into
Kelly after she apologized she
apologized and then lack said well there
is no other way to put this but I
condemn those remarks there's no place
on our air or in this workplace for them
very unfortunate and then Lester Holt
covered her comments on NBC Nightly News
hey so the NBC decided to eat their own
by going after megyn kelly it's amazing
how convenient that is right no one on
CNN criticizes CNN nobody on NBC News
criticizes NBC News unless they are
preparing to chop somebody up and throw
them in the wood chipper and that's
basically what NBC is doing here I
wonder why nobody trusts the media I
mean this is this it really is a great
media story of just how corrupt the
media are there's no question that NBC
is just attempting to flame the the
stoke the flames here in order so that
they can make a move on megyn kelly that
they wouldn't otherwise be able to make
contractually so well done over at NBC
making the country worse place so you
can save some money on a host that you
yourselves boxed in the wrong way
speaking of bad stories so president
Trump apparently has been exposing
national security secrets supposedly to
outside prying eyes now before you say
anything folks on the right before all
my conservative friends say Hillary
Clinton emails yoga I know it was bad we
chanted lock her up right I when I say
we not Nami but there are a lot of
people who said that she should have
been locked up now I said that she
should have been tried that she
committed a criminal act according to
the evidence that I saw with that said
that was bad you know what else is bad
when President Trump doesn't what about
ISM is strong in our country right now
here is the story from the New York
Times when President Trump calls old
friends on one of his iPhones to gossip
gripe or solicit their latest take on
how he is doing American intelligence
reports indicate
Chinese spies are often listening and
put into use invaluable insights into
how to best work the president's and
effect administration policy current and
former American officials said mr.
Trump's aides have repeatedly warned him
cellphone calls were not secure they've
told him Russian spies are routinely
eavesdropping on the calls but aides say
that the president who's been pressured
into using his secure White House
landline more often these days has still
refused to give up his iPhones White
House officials say they can only hope
he refrains from discussing classified
information when he is on them the
president should not be doing this now
the president has denied the accounts
the president says that he has not done
any of this that you know this is all
fake news again it's all fake news maybe
it's fake news and maybe it's not if
it's not mr. president please stop doing
this okay like really it's not good and
if we really believe that it's bad to
expose America's national security
secrets to prying eyes then we probably
shouldn't be doing it on our side either
in other news the stock market has taken
a massive hit this month it is now at a
full loss for the year remember already
in October so that means that all the
gains of the last ten months were
basically erased over the course of
October the Dow Jones Industrial Average
dropped 608 points at 24,000 583 and
erased all of its gains for 2018 the S&P
500 dropped 3.1 percent to 2656 and
turned negative for the year why while
the earnings are down so a lot of the
tech earnings are down and also there
are a lot of fears about the idea that
the economy was overheated in advance of
the of the tariffs that President Trump
has put in place against China
so people basically stocked up on
products before the tariffs were set to
hit and that means that there are a lot
of forecasts that the economy is
actually not going to grow as much next
quarter we have yet to see whether that
is the case also the housing numbers are
down there's a lot of uncertainty
heading into the end of the year
according to JJ conohan chief market
strategist at TD Ameritrade and just it
feels like people feel more comfortable
spending short-term rather than
long-term now it is quite possible some
of this has to do with the midterm
elections the feeling that Democrats
could get into power and then start
stymieing every possibility of
deregulation that they could be looking
to raise taxes again then it could look
to cut a deal with President Trump to
raise deficits and to blow out the
spending that's going to have some
impact on the market as well that's why
it's impaired
that if you like if you like your
economy if you want to keep your economy
if you like your economy you can keep
your economy but only if you keep
electing the people who brought you that
economy namely the Republicans in
Congress even more so than the president
the Republicans in Congress were
responsible for President Obama not
getting through his worst his worst
legislative proposals and they have been
effectuating president Trump's economic
policy for the last couple of years as
well now what are the chances that the
Republicans retain the house well
they've been moving in the wrong
direction in the house
there's according to 538 a five and six
chance that Democrats win control of the
House the Senate however is a little bit
different so they're forecasting that
the Senate is going to be held by the
Republicans in all likelihood when they
say that right now the the Senate is
about 75% likely that the Senate is is I
get yeah five and six chance Republicans
keep control of the Senate and they may
gain up to two seats two three four
seats they say that there is a a 17
point eight percent chance that
everything remains solid there is
basically well within the bell curve
that Republicans pick up anywhere from
three to three to four seats two to four
seats so that seems the most likely
outcome at this point you know all of
that has led people on the right to
suggest that maybe this latest bomb
scare is some sort of democratic attempt
to gin up voter rage just before the
election but again in the absence of
evidence I am NOT going to go there and
I don't think anybody else should go
there either we should not be moving
based on again
you know evidence list allegations at
this point I'm perfectly fine with
waiting another 24 hours to find out
what the hell is going on and I think
everybody else should be too if we want
to have a stronger and better country
okay well let's do some things I like
and then some things I hate so things
that I like I think that everybody likes
cartoons that's what I think I think
America can unify around liking cartoons
our country used to be a lot more
literate with regard to classical music
particularly my kids know some classical
music specifically because they have
watched some of the old D timey cartoons
now a lot of people look at these
cartoons like those cartoons are violent
those cartoons are violent if you really
again connecting speech to violence if
you really think watching tom and jerry
clobber each other is what leads to
people raping people or shooting people
you're out of your mind
my kids watch these cartoons and you
know what they don't do slam the piano
on each other's hands okay here is the
this cartoon actually wanted Oscar it's
called the cat concerto and what you're
going to hear is Tom the Tom's the cat
Jerry's the mouse tom is going to be
playing Hungarian Rhapsody number two by
Liszt here's a little bit of this
cartoon which is just hilarious
[Music]
so this is great this is the only
cartoon of this era that used classical
music they're a bunch of Bugs Bunny
cartoons that use classical music
particularly the Barber of Seville
there's a very famous one there is a
there's a very famous one of Bugs Bunny
and Elmer Fudd doing a a vogner opera
which is which is pretty great
there is one of Bugs Bunny as Leopold
Stokowski
the famous conductor it used to be that
people actually were cultured you know
this is one of the great lies that was
told in the 1950s about the United
States is that America was hollowing out
our soul was gone we're a bunch of
consumerist the fact is more Americans
attended classical concerts during like
1954 than attended baseball games
Americans were going to Americans were
actually there they're actually seeking
to educate themselves in new and
interesting ways and the availability of
new means of listening to music like
this was one of the reasons for that so
worth checking out and yes you can show
it to your small children and they won't
hit each other with pianos it's okay
okay time for a thing that I hate the
left love science when I say they love
science I mean they really don't like
science very much what they like to do
is speculate about science and then use
the weakest possible scientific findings
in order to push the idea that public
policy should be shifted in their
direction
the latest example is incredibly stupid
okay the latest example is from voxcom
the great explaining website that
explains nothing the piece is by Dylan
Matthews and Byrd Pinkerton Dylan
Matthews is just awful and here's what
they write how our drinking water could
help prevent suicide some researchers
think putting lithium in our water could
save lives a so they actually want to
lace the water you get from the tap with
lithium in actual psychiatric drug here
is what he writes lithium is a potent
psychiatric drug one of the primary
prescribed medications for bipolar
disorder but it's also an element that
occurs naturally all over the Earth's
crust including in bodies of water that
means small quantities of lithium wind
up in the tap water you consume every
day just how much is in the water varies
quite a bit from place to place
naturally that made researchers curious
our places with more lithium in the
water healthier mentally well there's a
study in 2014
reviewing other studies they found four
or five studies reviewed found that
places with higher levels of trace
lithium had lower suicide rates well
this one would fall under the category
of correlation does not equal causation
buried deep down in the article is this
news the size of the numbers that are
being claimed should make you skeptical
there are huge arguably implausibly huge
effects the open philanthropy project
which had previously been quite
interested in new research on lithium
States on its website that the study
makes us substantially less optimistic a
2017 study that trace lithium really
helps guard against suicide just this
year a study using healthcare claims
data in the u.s. found greater amounts
of trace lithium in the water didn't
protect lower diagnosis of bipolar
disorder or dementia so why hasn't it
been tried um because there's no science
that suggests that it really works also
if you really want to make Americans
paranoid really start lacing their water
good idea good idea guys you want to
make Americans paranoid start lacing
their water not with fluoride which the
crazies already think is controlling
your brain start lacing it with actual
psychiatric drugs to pacify the
population good luck with that see how
that goes in America oh yeah yeah well I
mean I guess we're all crazy enough that
we don't actually have to we don't have
to wait for the lithium we're all mutts
at this point so we'll be back here
tomorrow we'll break down more than
nuttiness and we'll do the mailbag I'm
Ben Shapiro this is the Ben Shapiro show
the Ben Shapiro show is produced by
Senya Villarreal executive producer
Jeremy boring senior producer Jonathan
hey our supervising producer is Mathis
Glover and our technical producer is
Austin Stevens edited by Alex and Garo
audio is mixed by Mike Carmina hair and
makeup is by Jess wah
Vera the Ben Shapiro show is a daily
wire for word publishing production
copyright Ford publishing 2018